with its mighty forces the mighty giant
at long last swings into action preparing
for whatever may lie ahead new keels
are laid for fighting ships in every
available shipyard as fast as new
battle wagons slide down the waves
test flights have proven the superiority of Uncle
Sam's choice of bomber types and have
given the final OK on mass production
billions of board feet of lumber are
making their way out of the forest by
flat car truck and blog float
Lumberjacks work at a feverish
pace to keep up with the largest
orders ever placed by the nation
still more significant of this huge defense
program is the smoke that fills the valleys
and rises from the plains across the length
and breadth of all America as the boilers
of industries operate under forced draught
24 hours a day the sound of hammer and saw
echoes between factory walls as new construction
and housing projects trained to keep pace with
expanding industry Secretary of Commerce Jesse
Jones announces that industrial production in
the United States is reaching a peak higher
than ever before in our history more than 3
million persons have already been added to
non agricultural payrolls the consensus is
that boom times unprecedented in American history
are ahead for the next three or four years to come
America Mightiest champion of free enterprise
the world has ever known earned the paycheck
of 74 billion dollars in nineteen forty four
billion dollars greater than the year before